a devastating and deadly strike on a
city up till now unscathed by the war
ukrainian officials say russia fired on
civilians from a submarine in the black
sea
veneza is where the ukrainian air force
is headquartered
this man explains the first floor of the
most heavily damaged building was a
medical diagnostic center which provided
people with therapy and access to
surgery
the attack set off a frenzied search for
survivors ukraine's national police
service says three children are among
those killed
this video is circulating widely on
social media the little girl is believed
to be one of the young victims
two videos posted put the child in the
area at the time of the strike she
attended a kids club hosted by a speech
pathologist
during yet another presentation to his
international political counterparts
vladimir zelinski said the attack was an
act of russian terror
in the east more bloodshed the head of
the russian-backed donetsk people's
republic accuses ukraine of shelling a
bus station in the city of donetsk using
a howitzer
the powerful long-range weapon systems
were provided to ukraine but officials
deny shelling the city donetsk has been
held by pro-russian forces since 2014.
ukrainians say russians
fired on their own location outside of
the country some diplomatic progress
ukraine and russia have agreed to form a
coordination center a step that could
see ships safely transport ukrainian
grain out of odessa a russian blockade
has stranded dozens of ships in the
black sea a full deal could be signed
next week helping to ease the world food
shortage
crystal gamansing global news
london